foreign
let's run out to Nicole in Kansas City
Missouri what's up Nicole
hey um thank you so much for taking my
call of course I actually had a question
regarding like relationships so let's do
it um my question is how to not be a mom
in a relationship
um at the end of my last relationship I
was really like the mom and the maid and
it was very frustrating
um I kind of naturally like to just take
care of my partner and my current uh
boyfriend he doesn't need a mom like he
takes service off he takes care of me
but I just like to take care of him and
I want to know like if there's something
I should not be doing so that later on
in the relationship it doesn't turn into
that you know same Dynamic of being the
mom and the maid again
um or how old should I act in a
relationship I guess I don't I didn't
really see that growing up so I don't
really know how a wife or girlfriend
should act
well I mean I I I
think asking a six foot two male that
question
um it's probably not I'm probably not
the person to answer it
um I guess my my 30
000 foot questions for you are
why do you conflate being a mother with
being extra caring and here's what I
mean by that some people are
um hard Chargers some people are
um I'm not gonna clean up anything
that's not who I am that's not what I do
I'm gonna I'm gonna film the book I'm an
attorney I'm a go-getter I'm an
architect I am a radio or whatever and
then some are like no no I was put on
this Earth to take care of the nest
right I just want to be at home I want
to take care of
my romantic partner I'll take care of my
kids I wanna take care of the dog I want
to make sure the house is perfect I like
cooking like and so what about what you
feel
or what you're drawn to
isn't working for you
because you called because you don't
like it but I don't know why you don't
like it
I think it's probably because like
I don't know I really like my current
partner and I just I guess I'm nervous
that
it's gonna turn into the same thing as
last time where I don't know I guess I
feel like I'm a lot sometimes and like
you probably are I am
I think my wife's exact quote is you're
you are a lot not end quote
yeah I am what's wrong with being a lot
I don't know some people don't like it I
guess well some people can go on move on
down the road
yeah
I guess I just want to get to the bottom
of like what you don't like about Nicole
when you say you ended up being a mom
did you end up was it because you were
dating a child
yeah he was very selfish yeah you're
dating it you're dating a child that was
sitting before you in grown-up muscles
right and grown-up skin
yeah
so I don't know I'm probably over
everything like the guy was
and he doesn't need it and he takes care
of me too
describe it break it break it down be
very specific what is it
like he doesn't
he doesn't need me to do everything for
him but he appreciates that I do it like
like I don't know if he's sick I make
sure to have uh or he gets migraine so I
make sure to have like Excedrin with me
all the time so if he gets a migraine he
has he can take the medicine or like if
we're like I'll cook and like I'll set
him down I'm like do you need water you
know but he also does that stuff for me
too I guess which didn't happen in the
previous relationship so I guess I'm
just
um
maybe you're uncomfortable because
you're in a
mutually affirming relationship for the
first time where you're going all in on
somebody and they're going all in on you
yeah now I would tell a guy if you call
the show I'd tell a woman this too if
you suffer from migraines regularly
as a grown-up you should have Excedrin
on hand right and so it's different if
he starts to get a migraine and he looks
over at you in the car and he's like
where's where's the Excedrin and you're
like I don't know and he gets mad at you
throws a fit like a child a temper
Tantra oh my God you said you cared
about me you don't have Etc if you dated
somebody like that in the past think God
y'all aren't still together
okay because that's that's an immature
guy that hasn't grown up yet right he
doesn't want uh he doesn't want a wife
he doesn't want a girlfriend he wants a
maid
and you're you're worth more than that
now if you love thinking ahead and
caring for people
good for you man we need more people
like you out in the world
it's this it's when you get yourself
worth
from taking other things off other
people's plates to the point that they
can't live their lives because if they
live their life you feel less than
that's when it's a problem
so yeah no that's not how I feel if he
pulled Excedrin out of I don't know of
the console in the car and you instantly
felt shameful that should have been me
yeah you probably need to deal with that
you need to work through that yeah but
if the goal here is I just want my the
guy that I'm kind of falling for I want
him to not have a headache whether he
has it or you has that's awesome yeah
and I think ultimately you gotta make a
list you got to make a plan of
here's what I will and I do want to do
and don't want to do and then you need
to be okay with it if somebody looks at
that list and goes I'm kind of out
yeah it's heartbreaking it's hard
and when you mention your ex
you almost got choked up
what's that still hanging on you
I don't know it's
God it's so annoying
um
it just sucks because
like I did everything for him and he
cheated on me and then he said no I do
love you and I still want to be with you
and then he kept doing it so it's just
like
I don't know I guess it's like hard to
dress like yeah that I'm not being lied
to and that it is okay for me to be how
I am
have you sat down with your new
partner and said hey
um I've been cheated on before so I'm a
little extra on edge sometimes
because if if I was dating somebody and
they told me that I would look them dead
in the eye and say and Roy I'll never
cheat on you number two anytime you feel
hey uh you ask and I'll tell you
yeah right yeah
yeah and he like he's been very honest
and hasn't done anything for me to just
trust him and I even asked him if he
thought I was acting like a mom because
I am a lot and he's like no there's a
difference between caring and being a
mom like having to be a mom in a
relationship so
yeah I think um I think this is less
than being a mom unless this is more
about you try to do everything you
thought there was a if I do this and if
I do this and if I do this and if I do
this
then he'll love me
yeah and I need you to hear me say
that's not how love works
yeah
the problem in that I thought I was over
it but no because it's not about that
dude this is about you
yeah for some reason you think way down
in your core you have to do X Y and Z or
you're just simply not worthy of being
loved and that's just not true
caring for caring's sake is awesome
caring so the people around you have a
better day that's amazing the world
needs more of that
caring because oh my gosh if I don't do
this and this and this and this and this
I won't be worthy of love that's
exhausting
yeah and I like to just do it do it
because I like to do it and then when it
gets to the point where I have to do it
because they don't do it that's when I
get frustrated that's it that's then you
become a mom
yeah right so if I get home from the
road
and I've got a I get home from the road
late like last night I got in a little
bit late got home and I've got a small
little duffel bag and I drop it on the
floor and I gotta be back at work doing
media first thing today
and my wife grabs that bag and she's
like I got this I'll throw this in with
your son's clothes
and the gasoline that she uses to wash
our clothes with
um that's awesome
if every day I'm just walking home and
dropping my clothes in a pile in the
middle floor expecting her to clean up
after me then she becomes my mom so she
stops becoming a partner who's helping
the whole household helping helping me
to ugh I have to that's a toy and
everything and you know the difference
between those two
yeah I was nervous that I guess I was
because one of my previous therapists
says that we trained people how to teach
us so I was nervous that my over caring
would train someone to just
I guess act like my previous
relationship which is just basically
like he said he'll just throw his stuff
down and expect me to clean it for him
yeah and that's it's twofold I mean
that's that's a very simplistic thing to
say there's some truth to it
but
so I I've talked to couples before and
let's say I'm just gonna just I'm just
gonna throw all the generalizations into
a big pot so if you're listening to this
everybody I know I'm over generalizing
everybody relax
um
but let's say she
it's a guy and a girl who are married
she does the laundry for the first one
year two year three years
then a baby comes along and she's
keeping up and she starts doing laundry
for year number four and then she just
hits a wall
gotta go back to work we have this kid
and then husband walks in one day and
there's no laundry
and he's like what in the world that's
usually the point where everyone goes
gosh that dude sucks he's the worst I
can't believe right
and there's some truth to that he should
be helping out and
the person who's been doing the laundry
for three years
should say hey I am running hey this is
I need some help here because often
people don't know
it's not a pass it's not like oh are you
kidding me no I'm not kidding you people
don't know they don't know
in seventh grade my mom or sixth grade
my mom took me down to the laundry room
put the laundry soap on the washer and
say this is the last day I do laundry
this is how this machine works May the
force be with you right I had a mom that
taught me a lot of folks don't
a lot of folks don't or a lot of dudes
just don't do laundry right ever ever
ever right so there's something to be
said for speaking your needs out loud
saying them out loud and then if he
chooses to reveal himself as a jerk I'm
not doing that I no Mana Mod's gonna do
laundry in this house all right well
this is where we part ways
yeah right that's not that's not
I don't see that at all here
so you do train if you will your partner
to just expect expect and if things are
going to change I think it's fair to say
it out loud what you trained your
boyfriend to do last time
is that he could do whatever he wanted
including other people and you are still
going to be a doormat for him when he
got home
that was what you trained him on
until you said no no no I have more
self-respect I'm worth more than this
I deserve more dignity than this Bye
Felicia I'm out
yeah see what I'm saying so I don't
think you trained him to like
always
I don't know washes little sippy cup
when he got done with it but I do think
overall he came to know she she's not
gonna do nothing
she ain't gonna do anything
and I think letting your new partner
know no I'm I'm serious about the
business of treating myself with dignity
and respect and being around people who
also treat me with respect and I love I
was put on Earth
to serve I love it it brings me joy
making your day better that's amazing
and somebody who loves you back won't
take advantage of that
yeah
is that fair yeah definitely okay
well you speak them out and I think that
may be challenge number one because
you're afraid if you speak your needs
out loud that somebody's Just Gonna
Leave You
yeah and you need to not be fearful of
that
Chris the second thing is I need you to
write this old boyfriend a letter that
you will never send him don't send it
okay somebody recently I told to write a
letter actually actually read it aloud
and I was like oh you shouldn't have
done that but
um I want you to write him a letter that
you're not going to send him
I don't want you to write it from
your heart this time
and I want the letter to be of such that
you are recognizing
I was a good person to date
I really cared about you and and I put a
lot into this relationship that as the
great comedian Michael J says is not
transferable I gotta start all over with
somebody else
but I worked really hard
and I forgave you I welcomed you back
and I forgave you again and I welcomed
you back and you you hurt me
and I'm not carrying your bricks anymore
as though I'm I'm somehow damaged I'm
somehow broken that's you can carry
those bricks if you choose I'm not I'm
done carrying
I'm out
and I want you to write that letter seal
it up
put it somewhere whether it's in a
shredder and put it set it on fire in a
fire pit whatever you want to do with it
I want you to be free of this guy I want
you to be free of how he treated you
and then be fully
ready to run into the next situation
with open arms saying I'm Nicole here's
what I need here's what I love are you
in
and give somebody a chance to fully love
you back
most of us hedge most of us hedge most
of us hedge give him a shot
give him a shot